on va terminer sur cette suite on va
parler de la caravane d'été de la
Croix-Rouge qui fait escale à la base de
loisirs de 50 ans en Yvelines ceux pour
la 12e édition lundi et mardi prochain
les 8 et 9 juillet alors Jean-Luc
guisselin la caravane d'été c'est à la
fois une initiation au geste qui sauve
et au réductions des risques enfin en
tout cas pour apprendre à savoir quels
sont les risques au quotidien et comment
les réduit bonsoir
pour commencer et oui l'idée c'est que
pendant qu'on est en vacances pendant
qu'on est
relaxé tranquille qu'on peut penser à
autre chose le fait de penser à protéger
sa santé sa famille et savoir quoi faire
en cas de problème sur éventuellement
passer une ou deux heures à une petite
formation
ludique et intéressante et forcément
quelque chose qui ne peut qu'intéresser
un certain nombre de personnes j'ai un
constat en France quand même toutes les
10 minutes une personne meurt d'un
accident cardiaque et un ménage sur deux
a été ou sera touché dans l'année par un
accident domestique c'est des chiffres
qui font très bien maintenant c'est
comme important c'est avec Robin oui
tout à fait c'est pour ça que la
Croix-Rouge a décidé de sensibiliser les
gens et à son message préparer vous être
prêt c'est au cas où il y a des
catastrophes que les gens soient
sensibilisés et sachent ce qu'il faut
faire alors concrètement est-ce qu'il y
a des ateliers quel type d'ateliers vous
allez pouvoir proposer aux gens qui vont
venir vous voir alors la caravane elle
va être l'événement est au tour d'un
village associatif où il y aura
plusieurs stands des stands de formation
va proposer des initiations au premier
secours qui vont durer une heure donc
c'est des formations qui sont destinées
aux enfants à partir de 7 ans on aura
aussi des initiations à l'arrêtduction
des risques bah qui c'est une formation
qui permettra aux gens de se préparer en
cas de catastrophe il faut savoir que
dans le 78 on est quand même confronté à
des inondations à des éboulements de
terrain et à des sites industriels c'est
les réseaux donc savoir que faire et
comment s'y préparer au travers d'un kit
qui s'appelle le kataki que la Croix
Rouge a mis en place et aussi des
initiations à la prévention des risques
domestiques qui est là pour reconnaître
évaluer les risques qu'on a à notre
domicile et pour appeler c'est quoi les
risques de mystiques on se doute que
c'est le feu c'est le gaz c'est la chose
qu'on laisse déborder que l'enfant chope
et se renverse sur le sur la tête l'eau
bouillante ou l'huile ou autre c'est ce
sont des petites choses auxquelles on
pense pas forcément
et pour lequel un petit rappel peut
permettre d'éviter
ce qu'on se dit toujours c'est dans si
notre action permet de sauver qu'une
seule vie c'est toujours ça de gagner
c'est clair sur ça de gagner quels sont
les gestes qui sauvent quels conseils on
peut donner
quelqu'un qui fait un malaise par
exemple quel est le premier geste qu'il
faut le bon geste qu'il faut avoir des
gestes qui sauvent ce qu'il faut ce quoi
il faut surtout penser ce sur quoi on
insiste le plus c'est surtout ne pas
faire les gestes qu'il ne faut pas faire
voilà donc quels sont les erreurs
la formation de Runner
une heure nous le principal c'est que
les enfants repartent sachant passer une
alerte connaissent les numéros de
secours si déjà ça c'est à qui au niveau
des enfants c'est déjà énorme parce que
on est la première le premier maillon de
la chaîne des tours même des adultes et
savoir donner les bons renseignements
comme il faut c'est peut-être pas
forcément toujours bien acquis quoi tout
à fait et puis maintenant on a quand
même des défibrillateurs un peu partout
dans les lieux publics que ce soit les
mairies les gymnases donc que les gens
n'aient pas peur de ces machines et ça
je s'en servir on leur aussi apprend à
servir de ce type de machine donc c'est
c'est le but après on va pas demander à
quelqu'un de si quelqu'un sait faire la
un massage cardiaque tant mieux après le
but c'est de repartir de savoir passer
l'alerte qui appeler quoi dire et c'est
le principal ces ateliers sont gratuit
tout à fait tout à fait on peut partir
avec un diplôme ou un petit attestation
oui voilà oui c'est pas une formation au
geste qui sauve sur le l'ancien brevet
de secouriste ce qui s'appelle
maintenant 1er secours civile de niveau
1 C'est le nom du diplôme d'état alors
on sait pas on peut pas le changer
il est long il est long voilà dure toute
une journée donc là là on vous fait une
petite attestation de formation
c'est surtout faire que les gens se
rendent compte que ils peuvent agir et
sauver des vies en
ne perdant pas de temps et en sachant
quoi faire ou quoi ne pas faire tout de
suite et en général quel profil des gens
qui viennent à ce type d'atelier est-ce
que c'est déjà des gens qui sont
concernés ou comme vous êtes à la base
de loisirs du coup vous avez un peu
particulier commun si je peux appeler ça
on va avoir entre quoi 100 et 150
enfants qui vont venir des centres de
loisirs
qui vont faire une activité
annexe disons et puis on va pouvoir
quels sont les gens qui se présentent
quand on a fait notre capital de
secourisme il y a il y a deux ans sur le
dans le centre commercial de
Saint-Quentin on est formé plus de 500
personnes
en grande partie des adultes qui
passaient on avait des grands-parents
qui disaient bah oui c'est bien de
savoir les dames qui disaient bah oui
c'est mon mari il a un problème je sais
pas quoi faire donc c'est bien que je
sache quoi faire puis c'est bien qu'il
sache quoi faire si c'est moi qui ai le
malaise voilà et
les gens sont assez conscience souvent
qui n'ont pas de formation qui ne savent
pas quoi faire qui ne connaissent pas
les gestes et obligatoire parce que bah
c'est plus ou moins prévu au niveau
scolaire mais bon comme toujours c'est
beau sur le papier mais ça marche pas
forcément très bien sur le mettre en
place dans les faits voilà et puis bah
c'est à la disposition tout le monde
nous faisons des formations régulières
nous offrons il suffit de notre sur
notre site Internet et
de voir que au moins une fois par mois
actuellement nous offrons une formation
de de faire des formations au PSC1
mais
oui la France est très en retard vous
avez des pays les pays nordiques vous
avez plus de 95 % des gens qui sont
formés nous on doit tourner aux
alentours de 40 ou 45 % c'est tout et
encore parce que beaucoup de personnes
sont formées sur leur lieu de travail je
voudrais un dernier mot sur les
bénévoles il y a 15 500 bénévoles à la
Croix-Rouge il y en a combien
15500 dans le secourisme
alors dans le secourisme environ 25
entre 25 et 30
toujours des bénévoles on est toujours à
la recherche de nouveaux bénévoles
avec des profils particuliers où tout le
monde peut toquer à la porte à
l'aquarium on accueille vraiment tout le
monde alors on les intègre dans un
premier temps les fait participer à des
postes de secours en tant que stagiaire
pour voir vraiment comment ça se passe
et si c'est vraiment ça qui recherche et
après on leur fait passer différentes
formations pour devenir secouriste en
passant le psor le PSE2 premier secours
en équipe et pour devenir secouriste au
sein de la formation demande à peu près
un an au total disons parce que c'est
pas du plein temps de toute façon c'est
quelques weekends par-ci par là
c'est important parce que on joue avec
la vie des gens donc il faut vraiment
sûrement très important de savoir quoi
faire n'importe qui est pas capable de
porter un brancard ou de savoir comment
sécuriser un brancard ou conduire une
ambulance ou autre donc il faut un
certain temps la première qualité du
bénévole secouriste c'est la motivation
c'est la motivation c'est très important
mais pas que pour les secouristes un peu
pour tous les bénévoles dans tous les
cas merci en tout cas vous êtes venus
sur le plateau du 7 8 donc je rappelle
cette caravane d'été de la Croix-Rouge
pour apprendre les gestes qui sauvent
pour apprendre aussi à mieux appréhender
les risques domestiques du quotidien
c'est donc les lundis 8 et mardi 9
juillet à la base de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines en plus c'est
gratuit
c'est tout à côté de la de la piscine à
vague et de la du nouveau
c'est la nouvelle tyrolienne
de nous trouver merci à vous en tout cas
les amis sur le plateau du 7 8